جائزه افضل ممثل صاعد في الدراما
التلفزيونيه في حفل جوائز جوي اورترز
بنسخه الثانيه ذهبت الى الممثله هيلدا
ياسين البالغه من العمر 21 عاما وذلك عن
دورها في مسلسل بنات ثانوي الممثله
السعوديه تسلمت الجائزه من الفنان ظافر
العابدين والفنانه ماغي بو غصن في لحظات
مفعمه بالفرح بعد منافسه مع الفنانه رحمه
احمد على المسلسل كبير قوي ومديحه احمد عن
مسلسل بنات الثانويه ونور النبوي عن مسلسل
راجعين يا هوى
او الفائز بجائزه الوجه الجديد عن فئه
المسلسلات للعام 20 22 مبروك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كفضل وجه مفضل تعال فئه المسلسلات تفضلي
شعورك بهذا الفوز
شعوري بهذا الفوز كان
رهيب كذا مختلف ااا
مختلط بين الخوف بين الحماس بين الفرحه
بين بين كثير اشياء يعني كان شعور ما ينصف
اها طيب الف مبروك
فماذا تريد هيلدا من المستقبل الدرامي
واعمالها الدراميه مستقبل همم ان شاء الله
باذن الله هل ده شخص مره طموح همم وكل همم
نقطه او كل انجازي سويه او كل شيء يحققه
يشوفها ان هو نقطه البدايه
بنفس الوقت الحمد لله انه اليوم عندنا
اليوم الحمد لله عندنا دوله قاعده تدعم
المواهب بشكل يعني جدا كبير وزي ما شفنا
في السنوات الاخيره همم كيف انه في مواهب
شابه جدا مميزه وجميله ولله الحمد وهذا
كله من حرص القاده ومن حرص همم المسؤولين
ودعهم ولله الحمد
وهذا الشيء يخليني انا فخوره
جدا ويخليني انجز اكثر هل سمعنا انه انت
كمان بتغني وتجيدين الغناء بشكل محترف
وممكن تتوجه الى الغناء يعني هل ده بدها
تغني ولا تمثل
شوفي هو التوجه الاساسي هو التمثيل بس اذا
كان عندي هذه الموهبه الثانيه ليش ما
استغلها مع التمثيل يعني داخله بالتمثيل
ما اكون كا ايوه يعني ما اكون كان مغنيه
لا يعني اكون اجمعها مع التمثيل لانه في
النهايه هو فن
[موسيقى]